Microsoft's announced plans to improve
its Bing search engine to include
artificial intelligence
my Microsoft has taken the tech World by
storm since it's launched two months ago
what's the first words that come to mind
when you think of Bing for most of you
it's probably slow old crappy buggy
inferior and unappealing I don't blame
you as Bing is associated with the
Microsoft which is associated with
Internet Explorer and we all know how
bad internet explorer was
in terms of market share it seems like
the whole world agrees while Bing's
market share has been rising within the
desktop space it's still struggling to
crack even three percent while Google
stands at a towering 93 so this seems
like an open and shut case Google
dominates and Bing sucks right well in
terms of popularity that's true but the
same cannot be said about profitability
and future outlook Bing is actually
substantially more lucrative than Google
in terms of per user Revenue in 2022 for
example Bing pulled in a total of 11.59
billion dollars worth of Revenue this
means that for every percentage of
market share they pulled in 3.83 billion
dollars conversely in 2022 Google search
business pulled in a total of 162.5
billion dollars while their overall
Revenue blows Bing out of the water the
revenue per percentage of market share
comes in at less than half of Bing at
1.75 billion in other words being is
over twice as lucrative as Google from a
per user standpoint if Google was as
lucrative as being it their search
Revenue itself would jump to 355 billion
dollars so while Bing isn't nearly as
large as Google it does seem like
they've been able to carve out an
extremely lucrative portion of the
market but this wasn't always the case
in fact about 10 years ago Bing was
losing money hand over a fist during the
worst of it Microsoft was losing over a
billion dollars every single quarter
with a bing and they were down a total
of 5.5 billion dollars within just the
first two years but after Satya nadala
took over Bing would finally become
profitable in late 2015 and since then
it's only gotten more and more lucrative
we should also mention that Bing's new
chat GPT powered search feature has had
a far better reveal than Google so
here's how Bing it went from abject
failure to holding its own against
Google
foreign
could worry about profitability they
first had to build a user base you would
think that the popularity of Microsoft
and windows would make this easy but
this wasn't exactly the case because
Microsoft was always fighting an uphill
battle with Bing here's the thing Bing
came out in mid-2009 which was during
the peak of the ditch Internet Explorer
movement in 2008 IE had nearly 70 market
share but this would plummet to less
than 30 percent by the end of 2013. this
meant that Microsoft not only had to
convince people to stay on IE but to
also did to Google and start using Bing
as you would guess this didn't really
play out all that well leading to the
massive losses in Bing's early history
but Microsoft wasn't willing to just
give in to Google so they started
looking for new ways to grow their user
base which leads us to their two key
strategies starting with incentives
Microsoft basically decided to pay users
to use Bing with their rewards program
if you're not familiar with Bing Rewards
it's actually quite appealing as a new
Bing user you'll be paid five points per
search for your first 10 searches every
day once you start using Bing regularly
and Microsoft can verify that you're not
just spamming searches to earn more
points you'll be upgraded to level 2
which is a lot more lucrative at level 2
you can earn up to 250 points per day
which translates to 50 incentivized
searches each point is roughly worth a
tenth of a cent so 50 searches is worth
about 25 cents clearly switching to Bing
isn't gonna make you a millionaire but
it can get you a free Chipotle every
month which is a pretty good deal for
just going about your daily business
with a bing it appears that a lot of
people feel this way given that there's
a massive Reddit Community with over a
hundred thousand users who focus on just
maximizing the value of rewards points I
mean these people have it down to a
science this user for example broke down
at every rewards Point ever Avenue and
calculated that you can earn up to
twenty two dollars and fifty cents every
month using Microsoft's various
offerings as you can see Microsoft has
been able to create a pretty dedicated
Community but bribing isn't their only
Avenue of growth much of Bing's Rich
volume comes from their dozens of
Partnerships and Deals Microsoft has
basically partnered with everyone that's
not Google the most notable of these
include Yahoo AOL duckduckgoa lycos and
ecosia and it's not just search
providers that Microsoft has been
partnering with either several years ago
they partnered with Amazon and entered
the e-commerce space and more recently
they partnered with Shopify to bring
Merchant listings to Bing on top of all
of this Microsoft has obviously
integrated Bing into all of their
product offerings for example if you're
searching on Cortana the Xbox Microsoft
Edge or the windows search bar you're
gonna be directed to pinga unless you
manually change your default search
engine and when you put all of this
together you get a user base that can
only be beaten out by Google and now it
is time to monetize
while Bing was able to go to a pretty
sizable user base one of its biggest
shortfalls is that none of its users are
exactly choosing Bing due to its search
merits as we discussed much of Bing's
user base comes from Microsoft's
existing products and Partnerships or
bribery so how could such a platform
become more lucrative than Google well
the answer is superior demographics I
mean just think about it what type of
person would switch to binget just to
earn a couple of dollars every month
well it's not the average person because
the average person is too concerned with
staying socially acceptable the type of
person who suggests to being it is the
type of person who is obsessed with
credit card points Airline points and
hotel points they probably keep around
their broken phone for eight months just
so that they can save 100 bucks on Black
Friday and they're the ones that scam
car salesmen not the other way around
but just because they're so conscious of
their spending it does not mean that
they're broke in fact they're usually
don't most well-off which means that
they're extremely valuable at Targets
now let's be clear here you're not gonna
sell these guys on the new iPhone or HBO
Max but an MX Platinum with a 200 000
Point sign up bonus now we're talking
these people are also the most likely to
entertain Insurance ads mortgage ads and
fintech product ads in fact 30 to 40
percent of all searches on Bing are
related to travel cars health and
finances meanwhile these are the top
searches on Google and it's basically
just social media platforms retailers
and food while Google searches may be
more relatable Bing searches are far
more lucrative when it comes to AdSense
because the long-term value of these
products are Sky High with mortgages for
example Banks can make hundreds of
thousands of dollars with each sale so
naturally they pay a lot more to
advertise their products than Walmart or
Starbucks we should also note that it
brings user base tends to be older with
a median age of 45 and given that people
tend to get wealthier with age this is
once again a win for Bing that's not
just the financial demographics that are
working in Bing's favor either ping also
tends to benefit from having more
desktop users as we previously touched
on much of Bing's success is
attributable to the desktop space where
they almost have 10 market share they're
virtually non-existent within the mobile
space right now but this isn't exactly a
bad thing because desktop users tend to
be far more valuable desktop users tend
to visit far more sites and they spend a
far more time on each site in 2020 for
example the average mobile user visited
2.67 sites while the average desktop
user visited 3.95 sites similarly the
average mobile user only spent 160
seconds on each side while the average
desktop user spent 351 seconds on each
site so naturally Bing is going to
benefit from having a more lucrative
Democrat traffic than Google
foreign
we've primarily been discussing
quantitative points as to how big is
progressing but the reality is that much
of being success actually has to do with
qualitative points and especially the
new Microsoft philosophy before Satya
Nadella the Microsoft philosophy was
that Microsoft is the absolute best
company and that everyone should use
everything from Microsoft whether that's
the Windows phone or MSN Messenger but
Satya brought a much softer perspective
to Microsoft since 2015 Microsoft's
approach has been more of how do we
combine our hits with our competitors
hits to create the absolute best product
as opposed to how do we replicate our
competitor success by ourselves in other
words Microsoft has shed up much of
their ego and they're much more open to
collaboration for example they launched
office on iOS but by far their most
humble move of all time was their
decision to ditch their in-house browser
engine and switch to Google school
chromium with just on wonders for Edge
and it appears that Microsoft is
bringing the same approach to Bing as
well the old Microsoft would have
probably just pushed out updated
versions of Cortana and that that would
have been their AI offering but new
Microsoft is embracing chat GPT all the
way meanwhile it appears that Google
still has a Microsoft's old mindset they
want everyone to use Google everything
they want you to have a Google phone a
Google OS a Google search engine a
Google AI a Google security system and
even a Google based smart home while
this approach has worked for them so
well it's only a matter of time until
someone does something better than
Google this already happened in the
social media video conferencing and the
self-driving spaces I mean Facebook
destroyed Google Plus zooms and teams
are destroying Hangouts and the Tesla is
destroying waymo none of this has really
hurt Google though because these
industries don't affect their main
business however the CMA cannot be said
about chat GPT chat GPT is a direct
replacement to traditional search
engines and it's already doing
extraordinarily well now Google does
have their own version of chat GPT
called Google bard which is supposed to
come out soon and who knows it could be
way better than chat gbt but we
shouldn't note that initial Impressions
aren't giving it much credit I mean just
take a look at this Microsoft was able
to get 1 million people on a wait list
within 48 hours for the new chat GPT
powered Bing meanwhile Google ended up
losing a hundred billion dollars worth
of market cap after their barred
announcement now again for all we know
Bard could be a massive success but this
is just the latest example of Google
being stuck in their ways just like most
companies Microsoft however has become
surprisingly flexible and either bad
that this will turn out to be far more
sustainable over the long term
foreign
came out during a time when Microsoft
hit was at an absolute Peak people hated
I.E and they would go on to hate windows
8. so naturally they didn't want to try
anything that came out of Microsoft
consequently Microsoft ended up losing
billions with the Bing within just the
first few years they were able to turn
this around though by offering appealing
incentives and making key Partnerships
which attracted quite a lucrative user
base but their real turnaround for being
it didn't comment on Microsoft to stop
forcing their products to an intolerable
level for the first time people actually
started to use Edge and being out of
Free Will and now one million people are
excited for a chat GPT powered thing I
mean just think about that they're
excited for being
clearly Microsoft is turning things
around in a ginormous way and who knows
in a decade Bing may not only be the
more lucrative search engine but also
the larger search engine are you guys
excited for the new Bing comment that
down below also drop a like if you would
like to see some actual competition in
the search space and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community such
as fertility ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one
foreign